you to dance et squeeze aujourd'hui on
va jouer un petit jeu via twitter c'est
simple je vais décider des personnalités
à l'aide de ses feutres et de ses
feuilles et vous êtes par devinez qui
c'est oh [ __ ] ça promet mal barré
oh ça va être dur mais je vous emmerde
ces partis ont commencé avec un premier
très simple tâche pour le premier foot
je m'en fous partout mais canal fox
le syndrome e école primaire quoi alors
là je vous le dis elle est parfaite qui
est cette femme
voilà un homme dès le premier des
premiers jeux prend des claques comme ça
c'est horrible
miley n'en lady gaga n'en bike lara
croft
j'en fais pas des pièces dont la vie
jamais bien sûr que c'est lara croft
[ __ ] quand vous avez pu vous trompez
regarder cette paire de seins ça peut
être que la récurrence dans un premier
temps ensuite pour la coupe en fait je
voulais faire une queue de cheval a
souvent des queues de cheval c'est plus
pratique pour les mouvements mais je ne
sais pas faire les queues de cheval donc
j'ai fait une queue de côté ensuite ces
pistolets là c'est l indice ultime vous
m'entendez avec mes gros célèbre
attention dessin numéro 2 qui n'est pas
des moindres qui est cet homme
maitre gims bah ouais bah du coup je
peux pas dire non c'est vrai obama nous
mais bien [ __ ] la kanye west
bah oui jamel debbouze avec la main dans
la poche ah non ah bah non je n'ai pas
trouvé cela je suis déçu mois voire
moins pour moi c'était will smith en
fait mais pour vous c'était tous les
autres noir de la planète
j'avoue c'est un dessin piège voilà je
suis des petites fourberie il est vrai
que bon qui est cet homme là mêmes
d'état vous trouvez par le rire jaune
non bart simpson
non le personnage de quick tu sors le
petit bonhomme de biko tulle ont rejoint
tout de suite un homme citron mais non
mais à la fin mais c'est jacky shot non
non là j'arrête tout géré tout ça troll
un [ __ ] j'ai voulu faire jo mais
regardez ce que j'ai fais quoi
on dirait ma gueule en pire encore en
orange rouge messieurs vous l'entendez
hurlait il exprime sa peine tel un chat
qui est cet homme
vous ne pouvez pas ne pas trouver c'est
impossible à retourner tout est bien
fait en partant du nez jusqu'à la
bouteille de whisky n'est whisky la
bouche d'un dc gégé depardieu
la première qui répond elle trouve
direct si ça c'est pas le talent même
800 vols il a menti parle depardieu
maigre ah oui merde c'est pour ça j'ai
carrément fait pas vu la brioche mais en
fait j'ai mis la brioche d'emmener voilà
vous rendez bien compte de la chose
quand même c'est un remix de depardieu
bon c'est 1 2 par mx voilà allez on va
te cacher des feuilles d'ailleurs en
russie clé je vais dessiner d'autres
celle ci je vais faire un youtuber qui
est donc ce youtuber j'ai exagéré aucun
trait vraiment norman norma normes à
norman normal [ __ ] celui d'annie vous
regardez y accuse des normales
oh la la le mouton aka normanno j'ai eu
peur
j'ai peur j'ai cru qu'elle s'était
trompée des dons c'est bien normal vous
rendrez peut-être mieux compte si je
fais ça mais oui c'est bien moi
en fait je me rends compte que je suis
nul toi pour faire deviner un dessin
chaque fois j'insiste sur le trait que
tout le monde a retenu et du coup vous
trouvez un exemple si je fais ça le
dessin l'oeuf pourri du monde médical
youtuber ses potes là c'est un peu
violent comme ça pouf vous coups
violents
attendez la question se pose cyprien ces
prêts ainsi près de voyage
oui parce que j'ai fait des lunettes et
de la barre vous dites cyprien alors
fait si je veux me faire moi qu'est ce
que je peux m non vous n'êtes pas gentil
mdr tu aimes les dents jaunes non toi
toi ou tu es toi avec tes magnifiques
dans non merci à ces méchants les dents
jaunes
serait ce un autoportrait jeunesse et
plus jamais c'est ça non mais non mais
non non non non maman on rigole mais la
gibelotte mais ok mais carrément vexé
quoi je les dessins et tout pour vous et
là vous me levais bon suivant allez on
passe aux choses sérieuses un facile
mais que je fais avec sérieux non ma
gueule pas m'engueuler pas je vous jure
je me suis donné à fond sur ce large
grecque drake drake fini c'est qu'il
dessine bien non mais avoue ne devrait
pas douter chiffres etc sinon viens d'un
petit potable juste la regarde et obtint
bon je vois venir très bien en soi faire
maintenant c'est qu'on va reverser
déroule vous allez me dire quoi dessiner
ok ok ok kim kardashian voilà j'ai
dessiné kim kardashian et c'est aussi
valable avec nicki minaj je suis en
train de réviser mon bac blanc français
je peux pas comme si compliqué à faire
ça et moellons la prochaine fois voilà
ça c'est toi qui révise ton bac de
français qui du coup peuvent pas même
celle en dire plus qu'il ya des feuilles
a4 qui essayent de kidnapper fait
attention fait attention et on croirait
jamais monsieur l'agent comédie ou pas
on va rester sur le banc ça m'a bien sûr
mais il veut il ya aucun problème qui me
faut du noir et du jaune c'est ça c'est
parti ça sont solitaires du rhum je
l'imprimé le talent qu pas de
l'imprimante voyez talent il était sous
l'aisselle tout à l'heure et ben là il
est il est carrément dans le tee shirt
et je les prix comme ça hop l'art dans
le dessin non non non non pas su la pop
fois chuté de fait kidnapper toi une
sucette jeu paru si la tentation de
faire une sucette avec les deux perdu
été plus forte que moi une [ __ ]
lol bonne journée bonne journée
le premier objet à ta droite bah bah
c'est bah voilà bon je te défonce 'le
plus tard quelle note me donne 10 très
bien walter white alors là je me la
donnes moi c'est plutôt mal passée voilà
je voulais faire voltaire white puis
c'est devenu has de new ziana john voilà
où un ouvrier où cyprien si on fait ça a
fait partout c'est incroyable ça et
voilà moi je m'assis n'est pas
sélectionné au lam le talent est présent
encore une fois pu des oasis a très bien
alors je suis si fait que j'arrive pas à
casser une feuille victimiser par une
feuille a4 mais quel effet ça fait de
lui arracher sa selected allant du petit
doigt du corps humain bon va très bien
écoutez je pense qu'il est temps
d'arrêter cette humiliation n'hésitez
pas vu la vidéo ça vous a plu comme
d'habitude je pense que cette fois je ne
referai vraiment plus jamais de dessin
c'est la main sur le coeur et le coeur
lourd que je vous le dis je n'arrêterai
jamais avoir de petit con on se retrouve
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir
regardé que tout le monde puisse porter
l'édition